now to the ice we finally have some more  details about the return of the vegas  golden knights and the nhl  yesterday the league released its  schedule for a shortened 2021 season  to mark the occasion the golden knights  did release this video  showing their excitement it was kind of  haphazardly produced but obviously it  was intentionally  poorly made it's very funny the first  game for the knights will be against the  anaheim ducks  here on t-mobile at t-mobile arena  january 14th let's just listen to a  little bit of music  and there it goes teams will play each  other in two game mini series they're  going to try and cut down on travel for  the teams  and for now fans are not going to be  allowed at t-mobile for the games  practice for the golden knights starts  january 3rd and a reminder there is no  preseason they're just going to get  right  into things at the middle of january